the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right hello people welcome back to
the second week of our course I'm happy
to I'm happy to have this wonderful live
audience but I also would like very
briefly to address our video audience
who will no doubt be watching this long
after I'm dead on mi t--'s
OpenCourseWare so think of this as a
voice from the grave you will suck you
will sometimes notice you in the video
audience will sometimes notice that as
I'm lecturing to this lively group I
will turn this way and look up you
should realize that what I'm turning at
turning toward and looking up at is this
project this projection screen which we
will show you and it sometimes has this
outline on it which guides us through
the hopefully guides us through each
lecture and sometimes has other
information and material on it sometimes
it isn't worth shifting over to show the
video audience that image but that's
what I'm looking at when I look so
strange I'd like to begin today by
taking a step back by reminding you that
the order in which we're watching the
movies in this course is a little bit
arbitrary because I wanted to use the
feature films as the defining as the
defining date and that's the reason that
we made Keaton come first because the
general is an earlier film it was almost
a decade earlier than modern times but
the truth is Chaplin entered film before
Keaton and Keaton had certain advantages
when by the time he entered the movies
in part because of Chaplin's example
although also because of the fairly
complicated way in which silent film had
already elaborated itself after the
first 10 years or so of the 20th century
so I want to take a step back into that
into that early phase just before
Chaplin becomes a filmmaker at the at
the really in 1911 I think is when he
joins the Keystone the Keystone studios
just to remind you of a story that is
told systematically in David cooks
history of narrative film which you
which is part of our required reading in
the course and I hope you will attend
the
especially to the details cook offers
about those early years in Hollywood if
you read those chapters from cook about
the early years of Hollywood before
Chaplin the movies before Chaplin
you'll recall that one of the most
fundamental things that happens before
Chaplin even appears is the
establishment essentially of the
industry I was describing last time
certain the migration to the west coast
is worth mentioning because movies of
course begin their career in the United
States on the East Coast Edison's first
movie studio was in East Orange New
Jersey much of the the Biograph company
was originally located in on the East
Coast and a lot of almost all the
original the earliest films even the
earliest films that were put into
production and shown commercially were
made in the were made on the East Coast
why did people move to the west coast
why did Hollywood become the sort of
center of the movie industry what
explains it it happens very early so
it's and it said one might think of it
as a very important moment in the
history of culture of popular culture
because Hollywood remains for all the
changes that the movie industry has
undergone Hollywood remains a kind of
the the kind of center of what is now a
kind of global enterprise of moviemaking
what helps to explain the move to the
west coast nothing fancy in the back yes
they could fill year round
why is that important especially in the
early days
yes you don't you're not dependent on
the web you're not as deep not as
dependent on the weather the Sun always
shines in California you you if it's
overcast you can still you can still
film if it's and there's no there's
there's virtually there's no snow
there's virtually no there's virtually
no rain the weather is very canary
conducive to the making of film and
especially in this early phase when film
stock was what was relatively primitive
compared to the complexity of film stock
we had today the film star film stock is
so subtle that it may can you can film
in the dark you can film by firelight
even amateur folks owning camcorders can
film virtually in the dark they can film
by they can film by it but by electric
light inside a room in the or tape they
can they can videotape in that way in
the in the earth in the earliest days of
film you needed a tremendous amount of
light to expose the film and what it
meant that you were dependent on on the
weather
so that was one major reason but if
there's another one that's even more
important in some ways even though that
would seem a sufficient reason for
explaining why the migration to the west
coast occurred there's another even more
powerful one it has to do with the idea
of patent warfare yes yes the
environment of Southern California is
particularly conducive to a variety of
film projects there are mountains nearby
there's ocean nearby there's desert
nearby so and and of course that's also
something that makes it a new a uniquely
valuable environment maybe not a unique
environment but but a particularly
valuable environment for Lou and that's
a good answer and you're right about
that but there's something else that has
to do with conditions in the east and
Thomas Edison remember Edison what you
know what you know it in a certain way
wanted to lay claim to virtually every
invention in the early part of the 20th
century and he was primed to do so he
was already recognized as a great genius
as as as the as the premier
entrepreneurial inventor of his era and
he immediately as he had done but as he
had done with other projects of his
began to take out patents to try to
control
the use of movie technology he wanted to
become a the Edison monopoly he wanted
he was he was fantasizing that he would
that he would control the movie
what-whatever the movie industry would
become and it's an his company
fantasized it was going to take control
of that and in fact the Edison company
hired law enforcement officers and
according to some historians even in
some places hired goons thugs to to go
and break up the the the sets and the
the the the the the shooting of rival
producers who were according to Edison
infringing on Edison copyrights so the
other reason and another reason for the
move to the West Coast was a lot of
entrepreneurial movie makers wanted to
get free of the patent police they
wanted to get out from under the
scrutiny of Edison and his police and
and by running to the West Coast they
were able to do so and in fact Edison
was unsuccessful in controlling the
technology as as cook and other
historians have made have made clear to
us so the move to the West Coast is a
very important one and I will return to
the was cultural the sort of a
historical and ideological or
intellectual implications of his of that
move to the West Coast you know you know
in a few lectures maybe next week if I
if I get the opportunity because I want
to talk a little bit more about what
what it meant for American movies that
film was made on the farthest Western
verge of the society away from cultural
centers unlike the way in which movies
developed in Europe and I'll talk about
that implication a bit later probably
next week when we talk about the the
German the great German silent film that
concludes our segment on silent films so
even so before so even before Chaplin
enters the rudiments the more than the
rudiments the basic system of mass
production of studio-based production of
distributor of manufacture of the film's
in in in one place and then the
distribution system that that developed
in which theaters essentially rented or
purchased films from the producers
was already in place and of course the
two great figures here is it is Thomas
Ince the great thing and and Cooke
writes very well about it and his
contribution to me he's probably the
person we can to whom we could attribute
the invention of the movie studio I
suppose and Mack Sennett who who
developed the Keystone studios out of
which so many important early comedies
emerged and the studio to which chaplet
to which which Chaplin joined when he
came to the United States in nineteen
two to become a movie maker at the after
the I think nineteen eleven or nine or
nineteen twelve so so in sand Mack
Sennett are important but one might say
one further thing about about this
moment as you know if you've read Cooke
Sennett created what came to be called
the Keystone studios and they were named
Keystone studios were named I think or
maybe it was the reverse I'm not sure
was associated with their prime product
in the early days and they were called
the Keystone Cops comedies we're gonna
show you a fragment of those in a moment
they were frenzied action frenzied
physical frenzied physical action so
this is the era this is the moment the
period the the before in the firt in the
first ten years of the movie industry in
the United States when the basic system
is being is being by trial and error
worked out and by the time Chaplin comes
to join the system after the first
decade or so of the 20th century the
system essentially is in place there are
already a number of famous performers in
both in comedy and in and in drama there
are there are emerging certain
particular Studios that's that who have
refined a mass production technique to
produce their movies on a regular basis
so an expanding and expanding market for
the movies is being met by a systematic
manufacturing process that intz and
Senate begin to work out in in in in
systematic and and long-lasting ways in
ways that in a certain sense continue in
residual form invested you'll form to
dominate them product
movies even today when we were talking
about the primitiveness and the
simplicity of early film there was one
film I had on the stocks we didn't have
time to show you last week and I thought
I would show this to you as a way of
illustrating again how relatively simple
the early films are see how much how
influential that first sneeze was the
name of this film is the whole damn
family there's mister damn there's mrs.
Helen damn
there's their son Jimmy damn
they said the simplicity of these
movements are part of what's interesting
to us I mean this is still an era in
which people are just fascinated by the
idea that movies capture movies but
what's the joke here and it the joke is
embedded I suppose in the title the
whole damn family there's miss IP damn
there's baby damn what an actor
see how it's framed as if it's a
painting how stationary the camera is
there's the damn cook what's the joke
here finally we're going to come to the
damn dog what's going on there's a kind
of right
there's a kind it's kind of risque let's
ben remember we're talking about late
victorian post victorian era
what's the joke it's the play on the
word damn right it doesn't strike you as
shocking but in fact you if you said
damn you in 1890 or in 1900 in certain
quarters people step back into oh my
goodness there's a kind of semi
vulgarity there in other words the fact
that the it's not an accident that it
that this is not the Thorburn family or
the Smith family it's significant that
it's the damn family why because they
want to make a joke what's wrong with
the joke why is it a stupid joke for a
movie because it's not a visual joke
right what does it depend on it depends
on language right no it's almost as if
the whole point of this film depends on
a joke that depends not on anything that
you can experience visually but that is
resident in in a verbal trick and it's a
trivial joke it's not much of it's not
much of a joke but the film depends upon
it and it's it's evidence in a very
modest and and but at the same time
dramatic and obvious way of how how of
this process whereby the new medium this
new visual medium has to emerge out of
media some of which are not visual at
all but are verbal and it's as if early
filmmakers haven't yet learned fully how
to exploit the qualities of the medium
they're they're working in so it's a
verbal joke rather than a visual joke
much more powerful and much more
successful where the Keystone cop
comedies themselves and I have we have
one example of that to show you I'm not
sure that this is a characteristic
example but it's it it's close enough to
give you a sort of sense of what the
Keystone comedies were like before
Chaplin entered the game
the essential joke of the Keystone Cops
comedies or there were I don't know even
know how many they were perhaps hundreds
there were certainly dozens and dozens
they were immensely popular early short
films some scholars have film scholars
have speculated that one reason for
their popularity was that they made fun
of policemen that there was a an
implicit sort of mild and not mildly
anarchic impulse in these early comedies
because authority figures people in
uniform were being shown to be clownish
in some way the primary element of
course is to find ways to exploit the
movies capacity to show motion right and
one reason I want you to see this
relatively crude example is that there's
a certain sense in which a short film
you're going that you saw last week from
Keaton the film cops is a sort of
reprise of this tradition of movie
making although you can see how much
more his short how much more coherent
and character oriented Chaplin's of
Keaton's short film was but the way in
which especially the cops are mocked and
shown to be completely clownish figures
almost all of the Keystone Cops comedies
to my knowledge involved incompetent
policemen who engaged in mad active
chases which often ended badly for the
policeman sometimes they would end up
all poor flying into a river or an ocean
or or some other or some other natural
disaster
and I think you know you can also see
them apart I mean there are you know cop
looking that was actually a very
dramatic effect for an early film right
so there's an awful there's an awful lot
about this that would have interested
early early seeing that car turn over
some people in the audience might never
have seen that in the movies before and
one could say that these films in a
certain way anticipate a great deal of
the ridiculous action-adventure activity
that we see in films even today but this
is typical of those early films where
they'll make way they'll make incredibly
implausible jokes just for the sake of
making the joke and I'm not sure I'm
alright a Mack Sennett coming this is
the kind of comedy then that was being
made by the Senate studio before Chaplin
arrived there were also certain figures
Fatty Arbuckle who went - who worked
with the fat comedian who worked with
Buster Keaton is an is an example who
had already begun to establish comic
persona something like the persona that
Chaplin and Keaton created so they were
not the first to do this and there was
so there was a suckler and more already
somewhat more character oriented comedy
beginning to emerge before Chaplin
appears but Chaplin's entry into
American movies is also a turning point
a fundamental turning point as many
scholars have have recognized and and
it's a turning point primarily because
what Chaplin introduces I mean
introduces many many things - it's a
comedy but he introduces one thing
especially or at least two things
especially the first thing that he
introduces is what we might call the
principle of the slow down instead of
frenzied motion all the time in Chaplin
comedies there are moments of quiet and
in these moments of quiet and this is
why they're important what begins to
happen is an attention is thrown away
from violent frenzied physical action
toward character what Chaplin introduces
into movies is an intro is a-- is a
somewhat more systematic and serious
interesting character than had ever
occurred before and what follows from
that introduction from slowing down the
action
creating moments of human interaction in
which in which the interest is
essentially psychological and individual
rather than an inter simply in frenzied
motion and jokes and or or forensic
motion and suspense which is what you
would get from a Griffith melodrama what
you're getting is so this introduces
several things first of all it
introduces a tonal variation it means
that in the middle of comedies there
could be quiet serious moments and in
fact it becomes the hallmark of
Chaplin's comedy that it really is often
not funny or at least that it's based on
unfunny materials and that there are
poignant and moving moments and says
it's as if Chaplin combines comic and
melodramatic elements especially in his
best in his best work I don't mean that
when he came into the films he began to
do this in fact he discovered how to do
this in the course of his in the course
of his career about which I will speak
in a moment so Chaplin brings an into a
new interest in in in character and in
psychological nuance and because of that
introduces tonal variation a complexity
of tone that we think of the [ __ ]
figure as as indelible and unchanging in
a certain way his costume always the
same his face always the same the kinds
of problems he gets into always similar
and that's partly true but the [ __ ] was
not born in fully fully dressed in
Chaplin's brain he he evolved the champ
over a series of over a series of short
films in the in the in the period from
1911 through about 1940 thirteen or
fourteen and one way I can dramatize
this for you was to show you how Charlie
looked in the very first film he
appeared in he was not an actor he was
not a director in this film he was just
an actor and he was a walk-on actor he
was not the star the camera had an
immediate affinity for him and after
people saw this film the first film he
appeared in this is still from a film
called kid auto races at Venice it's a
kind of documentary about soapbox racing
and Chaplin the chaplain character had
just been hired by Mack Sennett to join
this Keystone studios and he made an
appearance in the film he really didn't
have anything to do but his appearance
in the film caused all kinds of interest
but in the audience wanted to know who
that character was why he
was so interesting and what was
interesting about him you can see them
the the beginnings of the [ __ ] costume
there but not not the complete [ __ ]
here's another early version of Chaplin
when his cook wearing a long coat and
not looking not looking very nice this
is Charlie is supposed to be drunk in
this picture that's one reason he looks
nasty and he's it's in a film called
Mabel's married life and he's he's he's
actually in conversation with the dummy
in this in this sequence but you can see
here that that the long coat it violates
our idea of who the [ __ ] was and so it
took a while before the Chaplin persona
well completely emerged and it was
partly a matter of trial and error
although very quick trial and trial and
error well I want to say a word about
Chaplin's career to give you a fuller
sense of of how swiftly he became an
icon and how significant his example is
for our understanding of the power of
movies Chaplin's dates are 1889 to 1977
he and his early child who was born in
England and he and his early childhood
is actually the stuff of Dickensian
melodrama both terms I choose with some
intentionality because there are
parallels between Charlie Chaplin's
early life and the victimization that
that Dickens dramatizes so powerfully in
many of his famous novels and there are
parallels between Dickens own childhood
and Chaplin's childhood Dickens the
great 19th century novelist who liked
Chaplin was interested in victims
layette laid emphasis on the on the
problems of ulnar about people of women
of children who wrote variations on what
we might call the mortgage melodrama all
his career his greatest works could be
said to be forms of melodrama I'm
talking about Charles Dickens the great
19th century English novelist and
Chaplin grew up in an environment that
was steeped not only in Dickens but in
the traditions of stage and novelistic
melodrama
permeated European culture and
especially English culture of this time
but his life but his life was a very was
a very difficult one in some ways as
well his his father died when he was 8
his mother was in and out of
institutions all of her life there were
periods in Chaplin's life when he was
just a little child when he was
literally completely abandoned and he
and his older brother spent time living
in doorways in the streets of London he
was literally a homeless urgent as a
child he what he began to act on the
stage from the age of 7 and almost
immediately was recognized as having a
astonishing astonishing gifts he worked
from 1906 through 1913 for a theatrical
company in England called the Karno
company ka rno and it was a company that
put on a certain kind of theater kind of
theatrical anthology in which there
would be skits comic skits and serious
gets acted out sometimes
when the skits were over people would
come and do something there would be
song and dance numbers sometimes just
straight singing it was a kind of a kind
of British variety show influenced
especially by the traditions of the
British Music Hall and the Karno company
was a traveling company first chaplain
worked with the company all around the
British Isles and then in I think 1909
or 1910 the Karno company made a
triumphant tour of the United States by
this time chaplin was one of the leading
actors in Minnesota one of the great
features of the Karno company
performances were pantomime performances
and Chaplin was a particularly brilliant
pantomimist so that and so he had a very
significant career he was already a
successful performer on the stage in the
Karno company and and and drew on
traditions of performing his father had
been a chaplains father was a popular
singer who actually had been songs were
published and he was he's sang in the
musicals for a certain period and
Chaplin's mother had visions or
fantasies of being a performer herself
and used to perform in privately to
Charlie so Charlie come charlie was
steeped in performance steeped in
theatre and as a young boy from the age
of seven on was a
ready sort of acting on stage almost
continuously after the age of eight or
nine made his living as an made his
living as an actor so as a relatively
young man he made a trip to the United
States with the Karno company the Karno
company toured various cities in the
United States was a great success a
second tour almost immediately followed
I think you know within six months and
on that second tour Mack Sennett saw
Chaplin perform and went and hired him
away from the Karno company we saw that
Chaplin had certain gifts as a performer
that would work in the infant medium of
the movies and hired him away and it was
an inspired decision when Chaplin first
joined the Keystone studios in nineteen
I think it's 1911 the date is in cook so
be careful of my date maybe a year or
two off but around 1911 he joins the
Karno company his first few films his
first three or four films he's just a
performer in but he has an immediate
affinity for the camera as well and
within half a dozen films he's already
beginning to direct as well as to act
and within a relatively short time he's
in control of every he become he gets to
be in control of every every aspect of
the making of film we can of the making
of his films we can get some sense of
how richly and symbiotically the
audience reacted to the the character of
the [ __ ] that Chaplin created by
talking in monetary terms about and
monetary terms about the development of
his career about the progress of his
career he joined officially joined the
keystone company in 1914 he was hired in
1911 1912 came over the United States
and from 1914 and 1915 he just that one
year he worked for the keystone company
and made 35 films in that one year
period he received what was then a
princely salary of a hundred and fifty
dollars a week the the final films of
those thirty-five the last fifteen or
twenty or so of them featured the [ __ ]
figure who had now been fully elaborated
in various adventures that became
characteristic of Chaplin's vision of
the [ __ ] and they were unbelievably
popular by far the most popular shorts
had ever been sent out of any movie
production company and they made Chaplin
a household name first in the United
States and then fairly quickly all over
the world so successful were those early
films that in 1915 he was hired away by
another company the axon a company es
ése na Y and for another year 1915 1916
he worked just for the SMA company but
his salary went up from one hundred
fifty dollars a week to twelve hundred
and fifty toppers a week in one year and
that's a gigantic more than a thousand
dollars a week in in 1915 ism is an
unbelievable fortune of course well he
makes only 14 films in that period so he
goes from making 35 films in the air to
making only 14 films and those 14 films
are more highly finished he spends more
time with them we can see in this period
we could see Chaplin learning we can see
Chaplin and acting in small the Fred OTT
principle we can see Chaplin and acting
and small the principle I talked about
last week in which we see him learning
to to develop performance styles that
are appropriate to the camera
appropriate to them to the sitter to
cinematic experience developing the
developing techniques as a director to
emphasize certain aspects of the tramps
character were experimenting with with
tonal variation in his films
experimenting with with various kinds of
comic devices some of which some of
which he imports from his performances
with the Karno company and some of which
he some of which he many of which he
refines and changes because he's working
in the movies one famous example of this
migration from stage to screen is what
is a bit that Chaplin was especially
famous for when he worked for the Karno
company he did a bit for them a
pantomime called the inebriate swell the
inebriated the drunk aristocrat that's
what a swell is a rich aristocrat who a
man about town the inebriated a drunk
the drunken aristocrat right and what
and and it was one of the most popular
pieces that he that he performed on
stage for the Karno company he remade of
version of it a very famous film it's
one of the very few short Chaplin's
where Chaplin doesn't play the [ __ ]
where he's dressed up in a tuxedo and he
plays the inebriated swell and it's a
film called 1 a.m. and in the entire
film Chaplin plays a man who is drunk
and who keeps encountering objects that
he misunderstands right so as an example
he comes across a clothes tree in his
house and instead of hanging his clothes
on it he embraces it as if it's his wife
right
that sort of thing and one of the things
that the the the the almost the entire
length of 1 a.m. has has only one
performer in the Chaplin himself and he
kind of he kind of recreates and
modifies what he had done onstage in
that performance it is in many ways a
very brilliant performance and shows how
imaginatively Chaplin the chaplain
character can interact with objects a
theme to which I'll return tonight when
I talk more systematically about modern
times and about certain of Chaplin's
favorite strategies for establishing
character so he works for the SNA
company makes 14 films including in 1915
a film called the [ __ ] fragments of
which I'm going to show you in a couple
of second in a few minutes
then he's so successful again and the
trend the 14 films he makes starring the
[ __ ] become international I don't know
what to call him international phenomena
bestsellers they be they and the [ __ ]
becomes the most sought-after and the
most memorable character in in in the
movies so he's hired away again by the
mutual company one year later and from
1916 to 1917 he works for the mutual
company in which he makes this time
$1,000,000 for that year and he makes
only eight films in that year so he goes
from from one hundred and fifty dollars
a week to twelve hundred and fifty
dollars a week to a million dollars a
year within three years right and and
each each move gives him greater
creative freedom gives him more autonomy
he begins to sort of really refine his
art and we can see the process happening
in these in these shorts in
in the films you're going to see tonight
two of the films
two of that both of the short films Easy
Street 1917 and the immigrant also made
in 1917 come from this mutual period and
I mention this to you because they're
already in some sense sophisticated
films even though they're not full
feature-length films and you can see the
Chaplin is bringing all the resources of
his narrative skills of his skills of in
creating character to bear on those from
there already in some sense
sophisticated works of narrative and and
there is a there is an apprentice period
that occurs earlier which I have just
described you finally in his career he
moves in 1918 to a company called First
National which he fought for wit for
with and that those are the people who
pay him a million dollars I'm sorry I
made a mistake
his mutual salary was a mere six hundred
and seventy thousand dollars he gets a
million when he goes to work for First
National in 1918 when he well when he
makes among other films one of my
favorite Chaplin shorts a film in which
we see the [ __ ] character playing a GI
in the First World War
it's called shoulder arms and it's a
characteristic Chaplin short except that
now but Charlie is doing is contending
with the kaisers army he's fighting the
word he's fighting World War one in
earlier films we'd seen him fighting ice
storms we'd seen him fighting against
hunger we'd seen him fighting in the
literally fighting in the boxing ring in
a film called the champion we'd seen him
working as an assistant to a pawnbroker
in a film called the pawnbroker a whole
series of jobs and tests by the time we
get to 1918 it's almost as if the [ __ ]
has held a whole virtually every job you
could imagine he then he can't hold the
job for long because he's a bum he's a
[ __ ] he's a he's Footloose again a
theme to which I'll return when we talk
about modern times this evening and then
finally in 1919 he moved the Chaplin has
become such a gigantic figure such an
international icon that he joins with
certain other icons DW Griffith the the
greatest most famous director of the
silent era and to Mary Pickford and
Douglas Fairbanks the
two most famous actors after Chaplin of
the silent era the four of them get
together and they form United Artists
minh dit in part to create their own
company so that they would be able to
control their artistic output and when
Chaplin working for United Artists
beginning in 1919 Chaplin goes to work
on his feature films and he makes the
great film the great silent features
that are at the heart of his achievement
he makes the Gold Rush in 1925 a film
called the circus in 1928 a more
imperfect and broken back film in some
way but full of his some of his most
imaginative comic performances one of
his great films in 1931 called city
lights and then finally in 1936 the film
you're going to see tonight already
deeply into the sound era a film that
remains in some fundamental way a silent
film modern times Chaplin then goes on
when after the sound era is over to make
a series of movies in the Sun in the
sound era and they all have some modest
interest for us because their Chaplin
films some some images from their Mahr
vet remain very famous to this day in
fact one of them was in the New York
Times today does any of you notice it
there was an article about a scholar of
Globes who had found evidence for the
idea that a particular globe in a German
Museum which was said to have been
Hitler's globe was not Hitler's globe
okay the guy but but in the middle of
the story what they were and anytime you
anytime a person of a certain age hears
the word globe and Hitler they think of
Charlie's film the Great Dictator you're
smiling why you know the image that they
have you seen the Great Dictator
what what what is the image they're
talking about yes there's a moment in
the film it's a moment of greed it's
it's not really a very good film I mean
Chaplin silent Chaplin sound films are
mostly of historical interest despite
what some Chaplin buffs would say his
great work is he's a silent artist and
this the the sound film caused problems
for him that he couldn't fully adjust to
but every one of his sound films has
interest and has brilliant moments and
the one you are remembering is one of
the most remarkable and astonishing
symbolic moments in Chaplin's work
it's the it's an incredibly ambitious
film it tells us how ambitious our Kamil
figure Chaplin was because he makes a
satire of Hitler and Mussolini in an era
when Hitler and Mussolini are not yet
recognized for the egregious monstrous
evil figures that we know them to have
been they were taken seriously they were
they had been voted into office
millions and millions of people thought
they were admirable leaders so when
Chaplin made the Great Dictator in 1940
or 41 he was doing something incredibly
daring and he was actually showing that
he thought the movies were art foreign
art form capable of taking on the
largest political subjects so even
though there are problems in the film
and it's not an absolutely great film
not memorable artistically in its own
way there are moments in it that are
remarkable and it's also a significant
document because it reminds us of
Chaplin's ambitions as an artist chaplin
was one of the very first filmmakers
along with DW Griffith I suppose to
realize that the movies had an aesthetic
possibility an aesthetic aesthetic part
of latent aesthetic energies and and
powers that needed to be that if they
were tapped would make the movies the
equivalent of traditional art forms like
theater and the novel and of course he
was right about that and he even made
some films that achieved that that level
of seriousness and resonance the moment
that you're remembering what happens in
it yes it's a moment of sort of manic
Glee in which the Hitler character
played by Charlie Chaplin takes a globe
out and it's like a balloon and he pops
it up and down and we see him we see him
throwing it up and kicking it with his
hat foot like that and and but it's it's
a kind of fantasy of world domination
it's supposed to it's and it's supposed
to show what a ridiculous and infantile
figure this mock Hitler is and and it is
the most memorable image from that film
so in this article that really had
nothing to do with Chaplin there was a
picture of Charlie playing Hitler
kicking the balloon up and down and one
reason that I think it's significant is
that it's a mark of Chaplin's greatness
as an artist that even in his even in
his imperfect text even and even in the
films that really do not belong to the
to the category to the
important category of his love his most
lasting and valuable art they still are
part the images from those works are
still part of our common cultural
inheritance he's a very great artist the
first great artist of the movies and a
figure who whose imaginative creations
remain vital and alive today in a way
that very few artists from that era
remain similarly accessible and
important to people and some it's a mark
of the reach of Chaplin's imagination
that that this is so of his importance
as a figure well there's much more one
could say about the development of his
career but I want it I want to cut this
short because I want to show you the
moment I think I mean I don't mean that
there's only a single moment but I want
to show you fragments from the film in
which we can see Chaplin really
discovering certain aspects of what he
wants to do and also where we could see
Chaplin screwing up we can see Chaplin
at a stage before he becomes the the the
self-confident totally autonomous artist
he becomes relatively soon don't can we
can we put up fragments from the champ
from from the front of the [ __ ] this is
a film appropriately called the [ __ ] in
which and it's a fairly characteristic
Chaplin film but I think it's I think
it's the film in which among other
things Chaplin discovers that he can Mel
that he can marry melodrama and comedy
it's the film in which he discovers that
he can do effects that are pathetic and
poignant and sentimental and mix them
with comedy in ways that are interesting
so here's a scene where Charlie is
rescuing a damsel right he does it in a
kind of comic way he's a kind of bum
himself but he's always a kind of
chivalric figure can you jump ahead die
one let's just show the next one the
next one Greg I'm just going to show you
a bad moment here after he rescues this
what girl she turns out to be the
daughter of a farmer he's then he's then
hired by the farmer but by the by the by
the farmer
in gratitude and then we get this bit
and I'm showing you this but partly
because I want you to see that it isn't
really all that funny or that it's just
kind of easy slapstick
I don't mean it's that it's with it's
without interested obviously has some
interest but this incompetence is
inconsistent in some respects with the
coherent character that he's good that
he's going to begin to create I don't
mean I shouldn't it's never that the
[ __ ] becomes this fully competent care
but this kind of joke here look at this
that's that's his foolish joke that
makes him that trivializes him in a way
can you think of examples of that in
Keaton remembering cops where for
example when he's riding along in his in
his card and he he devises that that
that mechanism that ends up punching the
cop that would be an example of a kind
of it's a joke but it sort of violates
the spirit of the movie it's it's as if
it seems it seems a piece of debris that
is forced into the film that may have a
comic moment but makes the film less
coherent that kind of thing is
characteristic of the trip a bit later
in the [ __ ] I don't have time to show
you this this passage a bit later in the
[ __ ] we see Charlie confronting the
woman that he had rescued and
discovering for the first time is it a
long sequence Greg well put it up while
I'm talking if you can find it you can
see you can see the in this sequence
which I'll let run behind me while you
pay attention to my words and while the
camera looks at it and then comes back
to me you can what you can see happening
in this in this sequence is Chaplin
discovering how he can be not just
comical but but sentimental how he can
elicit sympathy from his audience create
sentimental effects and was what Charlie
has just done here in this image is he's
meeting the girl's boyfriend he didn't
know the girl had a boyfriend he was
falling in love with her watch his
expression here
see he's very upset by what he's learned
and that in other words this is not a
funny moment and and this is the moment
I think in Chaplin's career where he
realizes the films he's going to make
should not be thought of as simply
comedies at all but as something more
complicated than that as comedies with
heart as comedies devoted to character
as comedies that are interested in human
interactions and that discovery
tremendously enlarged movie comedy
tremendously enlarged the movies more
generally right and then we can see
Charlie saying Charlie says goodbye and
he writes this little sad message and he
and he leaves her so it's the moment
when pathos sentiment enters Chaplin's
work and in the film's you'll see
tonight you'll understand why after he
made this discovery he began to meld
these two elements more and more fully
together so what this is a way of
reinforcing what I call last week the
multiplicity principle what we can see
is that in those jokes with the
pitchfork there was no multiplicity they
were just funny because Charlie didn't
know how to use the pitchfork right but
later moments in this film and in many
later films we see Chaplin beginning to
create effects which have more than one
consequence more than one significance
for the audience one of the most
remarkable things about the chase scenes
that Charlie Chaplin develops and begins
to perform in his films and you'll see
wonderful examples of them tonight is
that the chase scenes themselves are
tremendously moving they're tremendously
comical they they're full of their
they're full of they're full of comic
bits that are just as imaginative as any
comic sequence one could ask for but
they do something else in addition to
amuse us they declare for Charlie's
character when Charlie runs away from
someone what we can see him doing is
using his intelligence using his improv
is Ettore capacity to figure out how to
get away so that even when he's running
he is also expressing his nature and
when the audience sees the imaginative
or clever or daring way in which he
makes his escape in a particular chase
sequence they're not just being amused
by a joke they are also understanding
his character in a deep way he's he he's
defining his character
even as he's also amusing us so we can
feel the multiplicity of that the
density the texture of that always a
mark of superior entertainment always a
mark I would say of art itself well one
way to clarify some of this and
especially to clarify Chaplin's
remarkable popularity is to talk about
the [ __ ] as a myth as a mythic figure
and if you think about his costume
you'll understand what partly what I
mean
he wears a coat invest that are too
tight right and pants and shoes that are
too big so the principle of mismatch or
of ambiguity is built into his costume
right and and many carries this cane in
this hat is he now he shows a kind of
elegance but it's a kind of shabby down
down market ellika elegance but the
question is does chart is Charlie
downwardly mobile is he an aristocrat
who's fallen on hard times or is the
important who has put on airs and
aspires to the world of of tuxedos and
fent and fancy clothes this question is
never answered and that ambiguity in his
character may be part of why the
audience is able to identify with him
there's a there's an uncertainty about
where he belongs about a kind of
mismatch or an ambiguity inherent in his
costume his body itself is a source of
his myth as well of his myth
mythological status its small dexterous
energetic incredibly graceful is one of
the great acrobats and physical dancers
physical performers that we've ever saw
that you'll ever see and in the film's
you'll see tonight you'll see many
examples of this including examples of
Chet Chaplin on skates enough Chaplin of
of Chaplin doing the equivalent of
dances and and of Chaplin of his of his
Dijkstra sness in situations involving
running or escape as a just as
powerfully as as one as as anyone will
see dramatizations of this just as
powerful as anyone could ever imagine
you know ever hoped for and then his
face so his costume his body and then
his face are part of the myth as well
he's an unbelievably expressive face his
face is a theater in itself and it was
Chaplin more than any other early
director who explored the implications
of the close-up and I'll show you some
examples tonight
of the power of the way in which Chaplin
manages to use the close-up for in in in
silent film for incredibly elet but and
to do so to do so and to be at the same
time what we might call deeply
incredibly eloquent a silence that is
eloquent because of the qualities in his
face and the moral qualities of the
[ __ ] are also appropriately ambiguous
he has chivalric qualities he wants to
defend children and vulnerable women
he's always a kind of defender of the
weak but at the same time he's an
opportunist and also a survivor and
these qualities don't fit perfectly
together and we see both elements in the
in the [ __ ] character again and again
again tonight in in the immigrant
especially you'll see both sides of the
chaplain character both his
opportunistic side and also his
chivalric side so so so he was so these
could these qualities created a kind of
mythic or a mythic authority for Chaplin
and there's one other thing that
contributed to the myth it was that it
was that there's a historical reality to
the hobo figure long before Charlie
Chaplin began to perform as a kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ] figure in the movies there
were real tramps in the society and and
that that the the the existence of a
genuine popular genuine population of
homeless people who they often rode the
rails they off and and and they were
they were they were present actors in
most most small large and small cities
in the country the fact was there was a
population of homeless people and that
that the [ __ ] figure alluded to and
reminded the audience of and that also
gave him help to help to strengthen his
his mythic power because it was as if
the audience was recognizing that there
were that in some sense Charlie was a
kind of embodiment or a symbol of this
of this social actuality so he was he
had a kind of mythic power that
communicated itself to his to it to his
audience and it meant that every
repetition of a tram film which might
very well go through the same motions
but put the [ __ ] in a slightly
different environment or a slightly
different job would be pleasing to the
audience some principle of repetition
and
variation right well finally the paradox
of Chaplin's work and the paradox I want
you to think about tonight it will end
with this point is that Chaplin's world
is full of comedy it's a comic it's a
comedians world although it's more than
just comic as I've suggested but the
irony of Chaplin's world is that the
comedy is so fundamentally based on
things that are so deeply unfunny
Chaplin's the most deeply social and in
some ways even political of directors
and I'll discuss this aspect of his work
tonight when we talk about modern times
and some of his other and some of his
other films but the crucial point here
is the Chaplin's world is a world of
Elemental themes virtually every single
Chaplin movie is about hunger aggression
victimization confinement I mean the
subject matter of Chaplin's comedy is
the less the less is the furthest from
comedy and part of his genius part of
what makes him such a remarkable and
important artist is that this immensely
unpromising material this disturbing and
in many ways frightening material
dramatized sometimes with full
frightening effect Chaplin often because
of his diminutive Ness puts himself up
against large figures giant figures to
emphasize his vulnerability and
smallness again and again the substance
of Chaplin's comedy is the substance of
victimization aggression misery
inequality inequity in other words the
subject matter of Chaplin's work is the
furthest from comedy and yet he makes
enduring comedy enduring melodrama out
of those on promising materials that
paradox is said about Chaplin's world is
at the heart of his work and it's at the
heart of why he why of all silent
directors his very best films remain
interesting today intrinsically not just
because they're wonderfully interesting
artifacts but intrinsically because they
remain serious valuable films some of
the films you'll set all of the Chaplin
films you're going to see tonight the
two shorts and modern times fit that
description as I hope you will agree see
you this evening
you
you